là j'ai ce
si que nous avons appelé la violence
espérances de stéphane hessel ce sont
huit pages où il y a apollinaire et les
textes des nations unies nommé nations
unies la charte des nations unies
oui de people's united nations et à côté
parce qu'il fallait garder l'ironie à
dieu de la guerre est jolie avec ses
chances et de loisirs cette bague dépoli
le vent se met la beauce ou pire
apollinaire la la déclaration
universelle d'ici la charte de sao paulo
que nous avons rédigé le 9 novembre
dernier avec michel rocard et cardozo
l'ancien président du brésil et qui se
termine pas s'il est urgent d'alerter il
est encore plus urgent de commencer
commence on est là on voit qu'il faut
commencer
et là nous avons dit au centre il faut
avoir tout ce qui nous fait honte chez
doha guantanamo sabra et chatila la
birmanie abou ghraib le tibet et surtout
casa et l'article 5 de la déclaration
universelle est quand même un peu
d'ironie avec deux jolis textes bien
pauline et incertitudes homes et des 10
vous et moi ne nous en allons comme s'en
vont les écrevisses à reculons à
reculons et l'autre j'aime beaucoup
aussi passons pas son puisque tout passe
je me retournerai souvent des souvenirs
son cor de chasse demeure de bruit parmi
le vent encore apollinaire chemise à
1000 belle tête la madame
pascal lemaître et on continue avec un
mur quel mur pas bien sur le mur que les
israéliens ont eu le toupet de
construire sur territoire palestinien
mais ironie ironie il ya l'article c'est
toute personne a le droit de circuler
librement et de choisir sa résidence à
l'intérieur d'un état ah là là et dans
le bestiaire avec ses 4 dromadaires
donne pedro d'alfaro berra couru deux
mondes et l'admira il fit ce que je
voudrais faire si j'avais 4 drogba l'air
je n'ai pas quatre fromages mais j'ai
encore une belle phrase inverse superbe
d'apollinaire dans la jolie housse il
dit à un moment donné nous voulons
explorer labonté contrer énorme où tout
se tait c'est là dessus que nous avons
terminé notre point d'ironie voyez on a
fait quelque chose qui peut être
maintenant diffuser largement dans le
monde
quelle chance
[Musique]
nous avons décidé de parler aujourd'hui
de la succession de mes engagements et
pour cela un peu artificiellement
nous avons choisi quatre dates de ma vie
l'âge de 7 ans c'est à dire le moment où
je quitte l'allemagne et où j'arrive en
france l'âge de 30 ans où je me trouve
au sein des nations unies de 60 ans où
je m'occupe du développement des pays du
sud et des 90 ans où je m'intéresse
encore et toujours au problème de
l'immigration
voilà mes engagements pourquoi est ce
que quelqu'un comme moi a cru nécessaire
de s'engager et de porter des problèmes
qui lui paraissait important même s'il
s'aperçoit que ces problèmes ne
rencontre pas les objectifs qu'ils se
proposent
et
j'ai quand même une chance pour un petit
berlinois qui arrive à paris d'arriver
dans un pari qui étaient déjà animées
par ses parents on m'a amenée chez marc
chagall
par exemple il y avait picasso qu'on
allait voir
à montmartre marcel duchamp amis de mes
parents partaient quelque chose qui
était un nom à la entre guillemets et un
oui à l'homme j'ai éprouvé du champ
commun un vrai initiateurs apprendre la
vie autrement que ce n'est le cas
traditionnellement ce sont des êtres qui
ont meublé mon imagination deux petits
garçons berlinois issu d'une famille non
conformiste dans laquelle les valeurs
morales sont joués par chacun à sa
manière pas forcément à sienne but
conformisme dans lequel il évolue
ce petit garçon déjà intéressé par autre
chose que sa seule école voilà qu'il va
rencontrer la langue française
de tout ce que pouvait m'apporter
cette connaissance des arts ce qui m'a
le plus frappé dès le début c'est debout
que j'ai de la poésie
quand je raconte quand je récite un
petit poème je vous en réussite 1 par
exemple un petit poème d'apollinaire et
coup j'ai cueilli ce brin de bruyère
l'automne est morte ou souvient temps
nous ne nous verrons plus sur terre
odeur du temps brin de bruit hier et
souviens toi que je t'attends rien que
dans ces cinq verres c'est peu de chose
a ouvert il ya quelque chose qui même
chaque fois ma femme me trouve ridicule
parce qu'à la fin d'un poème j'ai des
larmes dans la voix
et cet élément politique j'ai essayé
d'en utiliser toute la saveur dans les
moments des plus rudes udmo existant
dans les camps de concentration quand on
n'arrivait pas à s'endormir et qu'on
avait besoin d'être réconfortés je me
récitait une longue poésie et ça me
permettait de survivre
j'ai subi à peu près tout ce qu'on peut
subir dans une guerre emprisonné évadés
rejoignant le général de gaulle envoyé
dans la résistance emprisonné par la
gestapo passes en 10 mois dans les camps
de concentration
condamné à mort est sauvé
c'est dans un de ces immeubles que j'ai
été emmenée depuis le cimetière
montparnasse jusqu'aux une chambre de
bonne à eau dans l'un de ces immeubles
pas celui ci un autre et j'y suis resté
un mois péter ensuite embarqué pour
buchenwald et c'est à ce moment là que
yacht hommage a réussi à monter un
complot remarquable
avec l'aide d'un grand allemand ig inc
aux gones il a obtenu du médecin s est
ce que trois d'entre nous puissent être
amenés au bloc du typhus puissent y être
échangé contre trois petits français
mort du typhus
prenons donc leur identité et notre
identité a été envoyée avec le corps de
chacun des trois au crématorium c'est
ainsi que michel boitel qui est mort le
20 octobre 1944
c'est à dire le jour de mon 27e
anniversaire m'a donné son identité
il est mort le pauvre garçon il avait 22
ans
moi j'en avais 27 et son identité est
devenue la mienne et j'ai pu continuer à
passer à travers des différents camps de
concentration jusqu'à ma libération
finale après doha en avril 1945 sous
l'identité de michel bois tél alors que
mon nom figure parmi les morts morts du
typhus le 20 octobre 1944 dans les
archives de buchenwald je possède mon
certificat de décès tamponné par la
gestapo par les camps par les ssd camp
de buchenwald
voilà d'histoire qui a commencé ici dans
l'un de ces immeubles dans les chambres
de bonnes nous nous étions soumis à une
succession d'interrogatoire qui n'ont
pas comporter plus de violence que ce
que j'étais capable de supporter sont
les filles je suis content de n'avoir
trahit aucun ami je suis content d'avoir
pu subir cette phase de ma vie sans en
être définitivement
qu'est aujourd'hui la venue fâchent
j'oublie je n'y pense plus mais au bout
de tout cela et à l'âge de 30 ans me
voici à new york
me voici au sein des nations unies
qu'est ce que je fais c'est de
travailler sur la rédaction de la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme
c'est un moment extraordinaire dans ma
vie et je me sens engagé dans ce combat
ma déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme
il y à 62 ans dans cette salle où nous
nous trouvons maintenant elle a été
adoptée sans un vote contraire si on
avait attendu ou trois ans il aurait été
impossible de mettre tout c'est parti
d'accord jal y ont rencontré la guerre
de corée
l'opposition brutale entre l'est et
l'ouest
elle accuse ne pas empêché l'adoption
d'un texte aussi ambitieux aussi
précieux que celui là un texte le seul
auquel on a pu ajouter l'adjectif
universelle c'est quelque chose d'unique
pratiquement dans les annales des
relations entre granges état que de dire
il y a des valeurs et l challah et elle
s'applique à tous les hommes toutes les
femmes tous les enfants du monde captait
des états qui n'ont pas envie de les
garantir
et malheureusement il y en a beaucoup
mais cette lutte là elle est aujourd'hui
sans doute l'un des défis fondamentaux
pour lequel nous n'avons pas encore
trouvé les termes qui pourraient être
enthousiasmé et guider les jeunes
générations pour que dans ce domaine
aussi nous aboutissions à des résultats
la rue bannantyne direct martin krick
comme une fan page farnham théâtre ink
rigueur far far ont été heureux dimanche
2 mai de 10 h 30 à 12 jours heureux de
vous offrir des cigares mandy donc
madlib le feu distincts y est en deux
parties
on y va enea michael coogan des zones
folman my time buchenwald et bénédicte
par sms mais la malédiction garaf
deutschland
c'est un moment extraordinaire pour moi
parce que je rencontre le fils de
l'homme qui a été pour moi
l'extraordinaire chauvin si tu veut on
peut il ya un bon là c'est une
merveilleuse coïncidence non je dirais
pas coïncidence parce que c'est pas un
hasard une concordance de nos destins
c'est que maintenant ce libre ce joli
livre que j'ai écrit pour y rejoindre
toute sorte de poème que je sais par
coeur
que tu sois tombé sur ce libre et que tu
es pris la décision extraordinaire de
traduire en allemand veau et c'était une
décision absolument nécessaire que moi
parce que parce que dès le moment où
j'ai vu ce livre je suis tombé amoureux
immédiatement face qui c'est un livre où
il s'agit de l'amour l'amour toute la
poésie mais derrière il ya l'amour de la
vie peut-être reçu l'amour des femmes
tout ça tout ça alors on le sent alors
j'ai j'ai eu l'impression tout à fait
tout de suite que c'est un livre
extrêmement important 6 po et si
personnel est aussi émouvant alors
j'étais c'était sûr pour moi de traduire
ce livre immédiatement
[Musique]
ce que la poésie a peut-être de plus
fort pour moi
là où elle met la plus précieuse
c'est qu'elle est constamment une
préparation à comprendre la vie et donc
à comprendre la main pour moi la main à
lte et à certains moments de ma vie très
proche puisque je n'ai frôlé plusieurs
fois aujourd'hui que j'atteins l'âge où
la mort est là tout proche
elle ne pourra plus guère années
maintenant à venir accomplir ma vie je
la considère avec beaucoup de respect je
la considère avec beaucoup avec une
attente très amicale la mort est pour
moi une amie je sais qu'elle est là je
sais que prendra son temps qu'elle
trouvera sonneurs je suis convaincu
qu'elle ne mettra pas seulement fin à ma
vie à ma vie à la vie de mon corps mais
qu'elle ouvrira peut-être la porte à
autre chose dont je ne sais absolument
pas nous personne ne peut savoir ce que
c'est mais non je suis intimement
convaincu que c'est quelque chose
la mort n'est pas seulement la fin de la
vie du corps elle est aussi sans doute
le commencement d'un rapport de cet être
que nous sommes avec une autre dimension
de l'être et je cite toujours volontiers
à ce propos un vers de shakespeare qui
dans la tempête fait dire à prospero
we and staff date du ring hamid envie
and our que life without by sleep
nous sommes de la substance nous on fait
des rêves et notre courte vie est
entourée par un sommeil oui j'ai
l'impression que je suis sorti d'un
sommeil en naissant et que je vais
rentrer dans ce même sommeil en mourant
et que c'est ce sommet ce sommeil qui
nous entoure tout ce qui fait ensemble
la substance de l'humanité qui doivent
accueillir comme il m'a ouvert à la vie
au moment de ma naissance
j'ai donc avec cette chose étrange
qu'est la mort une relation à la fois
comme je lisais amical non seulement
elle ne fait pas peur mais je pense
qu'elle n'accueillera avec la même
gentillesse que j'ai été accueilli tout
au long de ma vie par les êtres que
vient rencontrer je lui fais confiance
je n'ai pas envie de souffrir mais
mourir trouver des moments où cette vie
sa chaîne et mon bras à autre chose
c'est quelque chose à quoi s'attache
beaucoup d'importance et à laquelle je
me prépare avec cette confiance que m'a
inspiré ma propre et
le tiroir le voilà comme vous voyez
c'est un tiroir est haché plein mais en
plein désordre alors quel jeu qu'on
trouve là dans tenez par exemple la
carte d'identité de mon frère âgé de
plus de trois ans que moi et qui est
maria maintenant cinq ans
là c'est un quart des photos sans grand
intérêt
et voilà une petite photo avec mon ami
michel rocard alors celui là il restait
proche de moi jusqu'à ces jours ci et
j'admire ce qu'il fait actuellement il
fait un effort pour lutter contre en
faveur du désarmement nucléaire total
ils voudraient qu'on supprime les armes
nucléaires y a bien raison et ce qu'il
va y arriver je ne sais pas tiens ça
c'est moi tout jeune c'est mieux bon
qu'est ce que j'ai en cas comme photo
amusante est clairement le jour du 60e
anniversaire de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme comme
par hasard on était côte à côte sous le
palais de chaillot
ça ne lui ressemble pas mais c'est lui
je peux vous l'assurer
trente ans plus tard nous voici en 1977
et je travaille au sein des nations
unies
je viens d'être nommé ambassadeur auprès
des nations unies à genève
c'est le premier poste d'ambassadeur que
me donne ma carrière
on le dit depuis bien des années un jour
vous verrez si les pays riches ne font
rien de plus pour les pays pauvres
s'il ne les aide pas à garantir un
minimum de leurs ressources s'ils ne
sacrifie pas un peu de leurs intérêts au
profit des économies sous développé un
jour vous verrez tout va craquer moi
qu'est ce que je fais à ce moment là je
fais quelque chose qui pouvait retrouver
une des parties les plus importantes
menant d'un jugement
je désire d'être parmi ceux qui
apportent une réponse au problème du
sous développement du mal développement
de la pauvreté effroyable de toute une
partie de nos sociétés humaines je
travaille sur ce fonds commun un jour à
4 heures du matin on nous réunit est en
uni ça y est c'est accepter c'est
accepté par tous le programme du fonds
commun je me dis ah quelle chance une
fois quelque chose en quoi je me suis
engagé abouti quelques années plus tard
on s'aperçoit que ce fonds tombe dans
l'oubli qu'on n'a pas donné les
ressources suffisantes à ce fonds pour
qu'ils puissent faire ce qu'ils étaient
destinés à faire zut
est-ce que je vais renoncer maintenant
est ce que je vais dire non le
développement ya rien à faire je ne peux
pas je suis trop engagé quelques années
plus tard je demande à pierre abelin qui
vient d'être nommé ministre de la
coopération
c'est la première fois de ma vie que je
demande un ministre de me recruter ce
n'est jamais arrivé avant pierre abelin
dis à très bien je vous fais chargé de
mission et je vous confie en particulier
une mission importante c'est d'aller
regarder dans les pays qui sont nos
partenaires des pays d'afrique
francophone
comment nous pouvons améliorer notre
coopération
je monte des missions de dialogue j'en
retire la substance d'un rapport rappaz
a plein mais ce rapport jusqu'à destin
le président n'en veut pas il est
oubliés dans des tiroirs
tant pis il faut recommencer quinze ans
plus tard c'est michel rocard cette fois
qui me dit est ce que tu peux rédigé un
rapport sur la politique française de
coopération à jeûner voilà enfin une
tâche
qui va me convenir et notre rapport est
accueilli par michel rocard avec
satisfaction
il nous dit oui c'est ce que je voulais
je vais en parler au président
mitterrand
voilà que le président mitterrand trouve
que tout ce qui lui vient de roccat ça
ne m'intéresse pas et il met le rapport
dans le tiroir est finie non ça continue
quelques années après voilà que lionel
jospin devient par l'irak premier
ministre parce que l'autre a fait cette
bêtise qui consistait à dissoudre
l'assemblée et qu'il n'y ait de
nouvelles élections et bien je
m'approche de jospin et je lui dis est
ce enfin de moment de réaliser ce qui a
été mon espoir une meilleure
compréhension par les pouvoirs publics
français de ce que peut être la
coopération au développement
oui me dit il et voilà qu'un aux
conseils et mises en place et ce conseil
va essayer de faire quelque chose et on
s'aperçoit que malheureusement les
gouvernements successifs de la france ne
donne pas la force nécessaire à ce
conseil est ce donc la fin eh bien non
je suis maintenant membre d'un collegium
international éthique scientifique et
politique qu'elle ne pas être l'objectif
de ce collegium avec beaucoup d'autres
c'est de faire face à ce défi que je vis
maintenant depuis 60 ans comme un défi
et c'est le défi de l'aide efficace au
développement et de la lutte efficace
contre la pauvreté
[Musique]
je crois avoir réussi c'est peut-être la
seule chose que j'ai vraiment réussi
c'est des pâtes et ma mère et pour les
pâtes et il fallait s'y mettre parce
qu'elle avait le regard acéré et quand
on était quand on vous disait une bêtise
elle vous me faisait sentir mais je
crois qu'à deux ou trois reprises
j'ai réussi à lui faire comprendre que
j'avais réussi quelque chose plus jeunes
qu'on ne le réussit d'habitude
ainsi j'ai passé mon baccalauréat à
l'âge de 15 ans eh bien pourquoi ai-je
fait cela pour une seule raison
épatez ma mère ensuite j'ai essayé mais
beaucoup plus difficilement des pâtes et
d'autres femmes
la femme qui a été pendant plus de 40
ans ma femme et qui m'a donné trois
enfants vitia était une femme difficile
à épater
elle était plus intelligent que moi plus
subtil que moi elle avait quelque chose
qui me faisait penser qu'il fallait que
je fasse un véritable effort pour ne pas
la décevoir
j'ai ensuite eu la chance de me remarier
après le décès de ma première femme et
christiane qui partagent maintenant ma
vie qui a eu la gentillesse d'accepter
de passer les années de sa vie avec
quelqu'un disant plus avec elle et qui
vieillissaient et qui arrivaient vers
les portes de la mort que nous avons
déjà évoqué un autre mot
et bien elle je n'ai qu'une manière de
l'impressionner c'est peut-être de ne
pas marquer trop fortement
ma vieillesse j'essaie de me comporter
comme s'il avait encore 20 ans de moins
je pense que la façon de partager son
amour entre plusieurs femmes et quelque
chose qui m'est devenu naturel du fait
même de la façon dont s'est développé la
vie de ma mère c'est toujours à elle que
je reviens dans tout ce qui m'a formé
c'est toujours elle qui m'a formé
elle a compris que deux hommes pouvait
aimer la même femme et que cette femme
pouvait être avoir des relations fortes
avec l'un comme avec l'autre c'est ce
que truffaut a repris dans ce film qui
d'ailleurs vient de l' aventure même de
mes parents jules et jim
et bien pour moi et me c'est quelque
chose qui se décline de diverses
manières
on peut et on doit investir dans l'amour
lorsque on rencontre un amour
lorsqu'une femme pour moi qui n'ai aimé
que des femmes
j'ai renoncé à ce que ma mère m'avait
proposent ils avaient pensé que ce
serait bien pour moi d'avoir une
relation avec un homme
elle aurait voulu que j'ai une rencontre
de type socratique ça n'a pas ça ne
s'est pas matérialisée la vie est comme
elle est on a refait pas je n'ai donc et
mick des femmes mais il m'est arrivé
d'être profondément acquis à l'amour
d'une femme est en même temps d'en voir
surgir une autre à laquelle d'une
certaine façon il m'était impossible de
résister ou de renoncer
du coup ça ne facilite pas toujours
vie des femmes vous savez son procès si
elle n'aime pas que l'homme avec lequel
pratique cette chose extraordinaire
qu'est l'amour tout un coût est une
autre femme dans sa vie il faut savoir
gérer cela avec prudence et c'est
difficile et quelquefois ça aboutit à
des échecs mais il reste que devant
certaines situations où tout à coup on
sent quelque chose d'irrésistible même
si on est déjà en relation amoureuse
heureuse avec une femme cette chose tout
à coup irrésistible nous amène à vouloir
nous dévouer à cette autre femme
et alors ça cause des problèmes dans ma
vie ça m'a posé à un moment donné c'est
le seul moment où j'ai eu contact avec
un psychanalyste ce psychanalyste qui
s'appelait je crois bien lebovits si un
grand psychanalyste a eu la gentillesse
de me recevoir
je lui ai dit m comment je fais j'ai une
femme que j'aime profondément mais une
autre qui m'attire profondément aussi il
m'a répondu ah je vois ce que c'est vous
vous prenez pour le bon dieu où j'ai dit
là peut-être raison
il faut que j'essaye de ne pas me
prendre pour le bon dieu et à ce moment
là je vivrai un problème de double amour
comme le vivent tous les hommes qui
n'arrive pas à le résoudre parce qu'ils
ne sont pas le bon dieu
tenez voilà un bistrot sympathique on va
rentrer là dedans
écoutez stéphane vous détonner dans le
paysage français
parce qu'un ambassadeur de france est
quelqu'un de très circonspecte très
honorable on est plutôt prudent dans
votre profession vous êtes d'origine
juive et vous vous intéressez avec
beaucoup d'ardeur à la palestine ou
conflits dray et loire et et kankan
cette sensibilité vous est-elle venue
pourquoi vous intéressez-vous as
tellement à cette question
à vrai dire j'ai deux raisons très
fondamental c'est de fait de ma famille
est à moitié juive et que donc la
destinée des juifs pour moi fait partie
de tout ce qui nous préoccupe
j'ai également eu la chance de
travailler aux nations unies au moment
où l'on créé l'état d'israël
les années 47,48 simultanément avec la
période où je travaillais avec cachin
sur la déclaration universelle moment
très important mais pendant les vingt
premières années d'existence de l'état
d'israël je vous disais oui bien sûr 1
les arabes ont dû souffrir de cette
implantation d'un état mais je me disais
tant pis c'est leur tour ils n'avaient
qu'à ne pas attaquer tout de suite les
juifs dès le début de 1948 et je
trouvais que jusqu'à la guerre des six
jours
l'équilibré était à peu près
respectables
donc c'est la guerre de 65 c lagarde
soit celle qui vous fait changer
d'attitude exactement après la guerre de
66 j'ai constaté qu'ils les israéliens
laisser passer toutes les occasions qui
leur était donnée d'avoir
de leurs voisins de la voisins arabes et
leurs voisins palestiniens
une attitude comme celle que je souhaite
à tous les peuples
c'était que vous avez été écouté par les
autorités françaises éventuellement
l'opinion française avez vous le
sentiment que vous n'avez pas militer
pour rien alors si vous voulez de plus
en plus et notamment depuis trois ans
depuis la guerre du liban
je m'aperçois que de plus en plus de
français est de plus en plus de français
juifs se rendre compte qu israël va dans
le mur
alors quand on le dit avec force on vous
dit oh là là mais les anti sismiques
cette absurde autres en ce qui vous
concerne c' est cocasse avant coca mais
en revanche dire aussi ah oui mais
israël c'est ce qui peut leur sécurité
est en cause donc il faut bien qu'ils se
défendre là je suis en désaccord complet
car je pense que dans l'intérêt même
denis sera elle qui voudrait être un les
états forts de la région et qui peut
l'être vers politique actuelle est
désastreux et les bouquets de l'homme de
l'onu l'homme de la communauté
internationale sommes des droits de
l'homme blob de l'éthique universelle du
donc là y'a un problème concret et il ya
un problème qui est un problème très
facile à comprendre
qu'est ce que c'est que les nations
unies c'est une organisation qu'intel
étatique qui réunit des états souvent
quand les états sont d'accord sur
quelque chose sur l'aviation civile sur
le sol et on n'a pas de problème de
l'onu ça marche ce qu'on dit un problème
qu'on se pose une question quand il ya
un problème aussi grave de dire un
problème de paix et de guerre
on a constitué un organe qui s'appelle
le conseil de sécurité quelquefois il
marche lorsque les cinq membres sont
d'accord mais dans le problème qui nous
concerne
le fait qu' il n'y a jamais eu d'accord
entre les cinq membres permanents bloc
venu devenu n'est qu'un instrument
je dis toujours l'onu n'est pas une
puissance j'aimerais que ça change
j'aimerais par exemple qu'un secrétaire
général élue mais élue par les citoyens
du monde est la force de dire aux états
écoutez vous avez la charge
lisez là vous ne faites pas ce que vous
avez promis de faire moi je suis là pour
vous demander de le faire ce serait
merveilleux
je ne suis pas un idéaliste vase vous
n'êtes pas un utopiste dans le sait mais
vous avez tout de même une fois dans
dans le droit international
oui vous avez une conviction que j'ai du
mal à partager stéphane montfort je n'ai
pas votre un petit minot roi ce que
j'admire c'est votre optimisme
finalement les optimistes sont un peu
béat et un peu passif il est un
optimiste actifs vieira j'essaye mais
vous savez la raison pour laquelle vous
avez une position différente nous est
très jeune quand on devient très vieux
on se raconte que les problèmes que l'on
croyait insoluble finissent par être
résolus je suis convaincu que des
nations unies dont on n'arrivera plus à
se débarrasser
heureusement mais vendent acquérir par
la force des choses ont déjà acquis sur
un certain nombre de problèmes qui
paraissaient insolubles un avantage
parce que tout le monde y est mon cher
stéphane vous me convainquent et par
votre vie
je ne sais pas si vous me convainquent
et par votre pensée mais je ne crois
qu'aux témoin capable de se faire tuer
comme disait l'autre et vous avez prouvé
vous êtes capable de vous faire tuer et
puis au fond il n'ya que la ville
existence les l'oeuvre des hommes leurs
actes qui font foi
et en ce sens vous m'inspirez confiance
c'est en quoi je vous considère comme un
frère cap ce que vous dites justement
sur la nécessité d'avoir un père il est
un péril visible pour susciter de la
fraternité
j'ai souscrit tout à fait je crois que
là-dessus nous sommes d'accord sur
d'autres choses nous pouvons diverger un
peu mais là tu nous sommes d'accord
mitterrand là il est en train de me
remettre l'ordre de grand officier du
mérite comme par hasard depuis je suis
devenu grand officier de la légion
d'honneur
ridicule mais il faut s'y faire et me
voilà encore on me voit avec le dalaï
lama à plusieurs reprises j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer cet homme
merveilleux
c'est un pacifique ce terme qui ne veut
pas l'indépendance du tibet il veut
simplement que les tibétains aient le
droit qu'on leur refuse de pratiquer
leur religion et voyez vous à quel point
c'est difficile de faire progresser les
droits de l'homme il y a des années
qu'ils s'y emploie avec toute jeune
intelligent sa sagesse et on continue à
voir
tiens c'est une photo ça c'est mandela
et ça a été une de mes joies de me
trouver à middelburg pour milieu de gens
qui recevait des prix de la fondation
roosevelt et mandela est arrivé vieux
merveilleux la reine la langue de
soutenait tellement au nab et de respect
pour cet homme extraordinaire
je voudrais bien trouver une autre image
mais je n'ai pas malheureusement d'image
de l'homme en qui je met maintenant
toute ma confiance je pense
naturellement à barack obama il a fait
connaître sa pensée dans des livres
remarquables celui en particulier qu'il
a appelée l'audace de l'espoir et
audacity of hope
c'est un terme que je reprends
entièrement à mon compte est maintenant
prenons la dernière date
trente ans plus tard j'ai maintenant je
pouvais en 2007
j'ai 90
30 de plus qu'en 77 et bien là aussi
qu'est ce que je vais rencontrer je vais
voir que l'autre problème qui me
préoccupe depuis plus de 20 ans le
problème de l'immigration
le problème des malheureuses immigrés
acquis que l'on prive de leur papier que
l'on ne veut pas régularisé et qu'on ait
said expulsés de france pour ne pas
peser sur notre identité absurde l'idée
alors que la france l'identité de la
france est faite d'une succession de
mouvements migratoires
depuis les gaulois et les romains
jusqu'au francs et jusqu'au 7 et
jusqu'au italiens polonais et autrichien
apporter portugais maghrébins africains
qu'ils nous ont apportés d'identité que
nous sommes et que fait le gouvernement
de monsieur sarkozy il nomme un ministre
s'appelle d'abord hortefeux ensuite il
s'appelle eric besson
que font-ils ils donnent à leur
ministère le nom de ministère de
l'immigration de l'identité nationale et
de la coopération pour le développement
et ce ministère sa tâche principale est
de veiller à ce que des gens qui sont en
situation clandestine irrégulière chez
nous qu'on trouve le moyen de les
expulser premièrement ça coûte cher
deuxièmement ça n'a aucune efficacité
car à peine expulsés ils reviennent mais
ça fait bien ça fait chic on dit nous
nous défendons notre identité ne voulons
pas être envahi par des gens qui n'ont
pas leur place chez nous au lieu
d'adopter enfin
une politique intelligente d'immigration
voilà l'objectif que je poursuis depuis
longtemps et voilà que j'en aperçois
grave échec en europe et en france
est-ce que je vais me laisser décourager
bien sûr que non bien sûr que
aujourd'hui encore je travaille avec mes
amis de france terre d'asile avec mes
amis de la rfid h avec mes amis
d'amnesty avec toutes les organisations
qui sont là pour défendre une politique
d'immigration intelligent et c'est ce
qui j'en suis sûr
tant que je tiens à peu près de boue va
continuer à me mobiliser
vous voyez j'essaye de faire comprendre
le genre de bonhomme un peu absurde que
vous avez devant vous il veut s'engager
il a appris de jean paul sartre quand il
était un jeune étudiant qu'un homme
n'est un vrai homme que lorsqu'il est
engagé et qu'il se sent responsable
paraît absurde
il ya peut-être d'autres choses à ne pas
faire dans la vie que de s'engager mais
quand on est une fois saisi par ce démo
de l'engagement
parce qu'on se dit que les problèmes il
faut les pousser
il faut les faire progresser et que même
s'il ya échec après échec il faut
continuer à les pousser et que un jour
viendra je ne serai plus là mes enfants
ne sont plus là mes petits enfants ne
sont plus là mais arrière petits enfants
j'en ai cinq maintenant ne seront
peut-être plus là mais ses problèmes
resteront et l'engagement pour les faire
progresser
pour soulever ce rush et que sont les
défis qui se posent aux sociétés
humaines
il ne faut jamais
mais y ont renoncé
j'aime bien oui on a fait quoi si j'ai
tout ce qu'il faut
il faut pas c'est bien gentil merci
vous avez vu une belle vision registre
il m'a alors à bord le problème
quelqu'un l'a dit on aime bien la rizza
guerre les uns qui fait bon vient voir
et nous sommes en train de regarder et
ça paraît dans tu te souviens chérissent
d'hollande béatrice dedans et ça alors
ça c'est un peu tôt avec arafat
c'est à la mouqataa et c'est bien plus
tard que nous avons été ensemble à gaz
oui alors gaza 7 en juin 2009 c'est à
dire quelques mois après l'opération
plomb durci nous arrivons à eretz nous
étions quatre elle seule toi et moi sans
explications sont admis à entrer et nos
deux amis sont refoulés nous sommes
actuellement dans un centre d'éducation
par le jeu d'une association
palestinienne
enfants de gaza et nous trouvons des
enfants très traumatisée très mal en
point et ce centre avait pour mission
essentielle d'essayer d'apaiser
psychiquement ces enfants qui vivent
dans une terreur permanente dès qu'ils
entendent un avion ils sont complètement
désemparés
j'apprenne vous apprenez beaucoup de
choses dans la conte et beaucoup de
choses dans le coeur dans la quête c'est
l'intelligence est dans le coeur
j'ai le courage et demain demain c'est
la liberté
bravo mais ce qui nous a aussi frappé
c'est l'hôpital qui a été formidablement
en dollars et nous l'avons visité tous
les étages sont démolis et nous avons pu
voir le faire complètement fondu on nous
a dit que c'était le résultat des bombes
au phosphore le plus criminel dans tout
ça c'est que l'on n'a bloqué chez un
million et demi de gazaouis dans un
endroit sans contact possible avec
l'extérieur lorsque maintenant débattre
ou vais essayer de rapporter au moins
arriver friture un peu de médicaments
l armée israélienne va s'y opposer alors
est-ce que c'est perdu
ou est ce qu'on peut espérer que sous la
pression internationale qui devrait
enfin se réveiller et cesser de laisser
israël jouir de cet épouvantable
impunité depuis quarante ans que quelque
chose va enfin bouger que ce rocher peut
être surmontée élevées pour que nous
ayons enfin une paix à laquelle toi et
moi nous aspirons maintenant depuis deux
ans
[Musique]
pourquoi ne pourrait-on pas considérer
que les hommes où la capacité et je
dirais la capacité grâce à la
philosophie
grâce à la métaphysique d'avoir un
rapport avec le livre avec le
transcendantale avec ce qui n'est pas
dans la vie immanente et dont nous avons
besoin dont j'ai de plus grand besoin
j'ai besoin d' anges j'ai besoin d'être
qui ne soit pas de la matière dont nous
sommes faits qui transcende notre vie
mais ça ne doit pas être ni un dieu
unique ni un personnage barbu qui ni
surtout le carcan d'une religion c'est
là que réside ma plus grande résistance
à l'égard de la religion est donc
particulièrement des monothéismes qui
sont les religions d'aujourd'hui ils
sont facteurs de violence et nous vivons
malheureusement aujourd'hui encore par
leur serment et la crispation des
communautés religieuses
un vrai danger un danger de
confrontation basé sur des appartenances
religieuses souvent artificielle souvent
avec lequel des des gens d d d un tyran
ou des terroristes vous pour essayer de
susciter de la violence et ça sam est
insupportable alors sans religion hausse
porte très bien
je mets une vie qui malgré le fait que
je dépasse maintenant 92 ans continuent
à être alimentées par ces engagements
dont nous venons parler ces engagements
sont connus et par conséquent je suis
sollicité est ce que c'est une surchage
non pour moi c'est parce que je suis
encore sollicité que je fais un effort
un effort même si je puis dire un effort
physique sur moi-même j'essaye de me
maintenir à peu près en bon état de
marche et c'est la raison pour laquelle
me semble t'il
il vaut mieux pour moi que je circule
encore à droite et à gauche au risque
d'embêter mon épouse qui trouve qu'on en
fait trop mais ça ne fait rien j'essaye
et ça me maintient en bonne forme et
c'est pourquoi je ne peux pas renoncer à
la multiplicité de ses activités
oui